con su voz intensas interpretaciones y
magnetismo Tina Turner se convirtió en
la reina del rock y marcó toda una
generación
la cantante actriz y bailarina
estadounidense murió a sus 83 años en
Suiza tras una larga enfermedad
relacionada con un cáncer intestinal
Tina es genial ella es absolutamente la
mejor sabes ella es mío y fue una locura
cantar con ella
[Música]
la artista originaria de Tennessee
inicio su carrera a finales de la década
de 1950 cuando aún asistía a la escuela
secundaria en 1983 alcanzó la fama
internacional con su éxito
y en la década de los 90 logró su
consagración absoluta que la llevó
durante años en giras por todo el mundo
y a mostrar su talento en la pantalla
grande en películas como Mad Max 3 a sus
70 años la artista anunció su retiro de
los escenarios acumuló más de 200
millones de discos vendidos 22 álbumes y
ocho premios Grammy artistas como mick
jagger y Mariah Carey lamentaron su
fallecimiento y también la Casa Blanca
Esta es una noticia increíblemente
triste Tina Turner fue un ícono un icono
de la música que tuvo muchos hitos y
momentos increíbles en su carrera me
entristece mucho escuchar esta noticia
la tan exitosa como dramática vida de
Tina Turner fue la inspiración para su
película de 1993 el documental tina de
2021 y el musical de Broadway que será
presentado este año en varias ciudades
de Estados Unidos
[Aplausos]